as the body count mounts in ukraine as
vladimir putin is reportedly attacking
even residential areas in his conquest
of the breadbasket of europe the
american establishment news media are
focusing on issues
that really matter like the effect of
the invasion
on transgender acceptance
cbs news is reporting that quote
transgender acceptance in ukraine is not
widespread and changing legal documents
to match gender requires a long process
with psychiatric evaluations
i suspect the psychiatric evaluations go
something like this sir do you think
you're a woman no okay you pass
yes you do sorry you fail
would seem like a pretty straightforward
psychiatric examination i digress the
network goes on quote cbs news spoke
with one woman in kiev who is now
battling a war within a war amid
russia's invasion
the woman of course is a man and the war
within the war is a sexual delusion
presently being crammed down everyone's
throats by an increasingly decadent
secular west but the news report is
actually a helpful reminder to the
warmongering globalist liberals who two
weeks ago couldn't have pointed to kiev
on a map
it reminds them
ukraine is not your toy
it is not
you it's merely the area of the world
where you can superimpose your own
delusions and your own preferences
ukraine is a nation and a people with
its own beliefs
and customs and interests
and way of viewing the world
and maybe if our leaders in the west had
had even a modicum of humility and
prudence maybe if they had shown just
the teensiest tiniest bit of respect for
those national differences and for
ukraine's unique and uniquely vulnerable
place in eastern europe
perhaps we wouldn't all find ourselves
today on the brink of world war iii but
i suppose that sort of basic competence
and judgment is too much to ask of a
ruling class that can't tell the
difference between boys and girls i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from marcus w who
says what i fear most about being
completely vaporized in a nuclear
explosion is that i might start voting
democrat afterwards that's true that's a
real fear people don't consider that
that even after the world goes up in the
bright flash and the mushroom cloud
democrats will continue to win elections
they'll probably win them by a greater
margin than ever before now when you
want to try to protect yourself if you
think things are going south you got to
get out of dodge you got to make sure
that you got wheels to do it in which is
why you got to check out rock auto right
now go to rockauto.com
enter the word knowles in their how did
you hear bettisbox so they know that i
sent you you're gonna and then send me a
thank you note because when you go to
rockauto.com you are gonna save so much
you could save 20
30
50 on your auto parts for the exact same
auto parts you don't need to drive to
the brick and mortar store you don't
need to answer a thousand questions you
don't need to wait for the guy to go in
the back only to not have your part so
that you got to go back and you got to
go online just pull out your phone right
now save save all that money they got
the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers there's no gimmicks
you don't have to wait until tuesday at
3 a.m to go log on it's a special sale
no always reliably low prices the
website is so easy to navigate even i
can do it you just go pull out your
phone
get on your computer type in
rockauto.com
you can see all the parts available for
your car or truck go get em now and then
write knowles k-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear bettis box so
they know that we sent you
the libs
make everything
about creepy sex they make everything
every single thing
is about their own weird sexual hang-ups
school you go to school now you don't
learn your reading writing and
arithmetic you learn about
transgenderism and throuples and
all sorts of weird kinky sex stuff even
a war in europe the first major land war
in europe since world war ii they
somehow make it about creepy sex because
i'm sure that's what the grandmothers
who are
in their bunkers right now in kiev
that's what they're worried about is oh
boy can the drag queens do they really
feel they can express themselves with
the bombs going off i sure we got to fix
that problem first then we can deal with
the tanks that are rolling into our city
the left is obsessed with weird creepy
destructive sex you saw this the other
day with john oliver
john oliver whose show i have never
watched but his clips go around and so
occasionally i am forced to watch them
john oliver made an argument that is not
a fringe argument it's very much a
mainstream left-wing argument that a
pressing social problem
is that we must right now
legalize
prostitution
basically consensual sex for money on
camera is legal porn and consensual sex
for money off camera is illegal sex work
makes sense right wrong well exactly
everything about the way we regulate sex
work in this country is confusing and
counterproductive and when we talk about
it it's often either demonizing
patronizing or just plain wrong and in
some cases all three at once but a human
history's worth of laws hasn't changed
the fact that one sex work has always
been part of society appealing to every
interest in every kind of clientele and
two sex workers are not a monolith
people from a variety of backgrounds do
it for a variety of reasons and the fact
is our current system of criminalizing
the trade and driving everyone
underground is actually only making life
harder for the most vulnerable involved
so the point of his self-righteous
monologue is we need to
legalize prostitution that'll be really
really wonderful
he's right that prostitution has always
been around it is the oldest profession
in the world it it's really tied with
politics for being the oldest profession
in the world and as ronald reagan
pointed out the two professions have a
lot of similarities they look they look
pretty similar when you when you compare
them side by side
that's all true
why would it follow then that we should
encourage more prostitution
he says all these laws against
prostitution they don't do anything to
actually reduce prostitution that's i
think what he's insinuating they no they
just make the whole thing worse this is
this typical
pie in the sky magical thinking liberal
argument that if you pass a law against
something you're not going to get less
of it you're going to get more of it
that's why we need to take away the laws
against drugs for instance if you take
away look you got laws against drugs
they don't do anything so we got to take
actually if you want to reduce drug use
you got to you got to legalize drugs
if you want to if you want to minimize
prostitution you got gotta legalize
prostitution because laws give you more
of a thing
right except that isn't true that isn't
true about any aspect of society if it
were true we would get rid of laws
against murder wouldn't we
because well if the law gives you more
of the thing
then we better repeal those laws against
murder tomorrow we're getting so much
more murder than we need let's legalize
murder let's we'll regulate it we'll
legalize murder we'll regulate it then
we'll get a lot less of it right no of
course not we pass laws against things
because laws actually do
disincentivize those activities
okay when you have laws against
prostitution you actually do get less
prostitution now we don't really enforce
these laws there are lots of difficult
problems with them sure okay you can try
to reform criminal laws you always try
to do that
beyond the legal point that john oliver
is making here is
a philosophical one
which is really bad his argument is to
really be free we need to be able to
treat ourselves like we're meat puppets
to really be free we need to
be able to accept money for for people
to pursue their bases most animalistic
sexual desires and for us to be treated
not like dignified human beings made in
the image of god but like meat like
little sex toys to be
to be
merely vessels for someone else's
temporary pleasure to be used and
discarded and thrown to the side
that's the argument here that we have
some natural right to do that that we've
got that that's the true height of
liberty but of course that's not the
height of liberty
and you see it beyond i'm really not
picking on
sex workers as the new politically
correct term i'm really it actually is
the world's oldest profession but it's
not good it's not conducive to virtue
it's not conducive to the virtue of the
sex workers it's not conducive to the
virtue of the clients it's not conducive
to the virtue of society there is no
right to prostitution whether you're the
person buying it or you're the person
selling it it's not it just isn't good
just outlaw it it's just bad and you
should enforce the laws and everyone
would benefit from that okay when john
oliver makes this point he says well how
come
it's it's legal if you have a camera in
the room right and we call that the
pornography industry but it's not legal
if you don't have a camera in the room
great question john you're right ban
porn you make a great point yeah that's
dumb that's a that's a ridiculous
distinction and we should we should
heavily regulate
if not ban outright pornography as well
sure okay that's a good idea
not but it goes even beyond the sex work
we are told now our kids are taught in
classrooms that
to be truly free you need to pursue
every weird sexual desire you ever had
any like weird destructive kinky thought
that ever popped into your head you have
to pursue it
because if you don't you're going to be
repressed and you shouldn't be repressed
because then you won't be free and if
you you're a man and you think you're a
woman to be really free you've got to
chop up your body and take medications
to to maintain these open wounds and and
pretend to and force society to pretend
that you're something that you're not
that's the only way to be free but of
course that's not true
the way we're now entering into a period
of lent
american christians are at least
christians around the world i suppose
and i think it's even for non-christians
this is a good period to reflect and
think okay what is the real way
to be free
the modern libs tell you the way to be
free is do whatever you want no the way
to be free is self-denial it's education
it's tamping down these face desires
cultivating your higher will but we
don't live in a serious country anymore
that recognizes that remember we we used
to talk in our country about sacrifice
we used to talk about
not being little children growing up be
a man do what you got to do
find your duty ask not what your country
can do for you but what you can do for
your country we're going to be a nation
of tough men who are going to leave a
better country to our children well
that's not the country we're in right
now it was this was so clear last night
at the state of the union address the
most
depressing
sad pathetic state of the union i have
ever watched and i have watched a whole
lot of them the state of the union was
really really
bad and
terrible and the worst one that i've
ever seen but i'm more interested in the
state of your household okay no one
likes to think about household
breakdowns but right now you should go
to ahs.com
knowles because household breakdowns
happen they happen way more often than
you would like that is why it pays to
have a plan from american home shield to
help cover the costs to repair and
replace things like your heating system
like your air conditioner like your
fridge they also know that no two homes
are the same that's why they have new
options to help you find just the right
coverage if american home shield can't
repair the covered item they will
replace it american home shield members
get more more coverage options fewer
exclusions from hvac systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
coverage available no matter how old
your systems and appliances are plus
they're offering an exclusive 50 off for
members of our community here for
listeners to the michael knowles show so
keep your home up and running and and
keep your budget on track with american
home shield right now our listeners can
take 50
off their most comprehensive plans go to
ahs.com
knowles save 50 bucks ahs dot com slash
and old say 50 bucks off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details i do
want to get back to ukraine because that
matters a lot more to uh
world security and the prospect of world
war iii than whatever nonsense joe biden
was talking about last night in the
state of the union but there are a few
things i've got to cover because they
were alternately hilarious and pathetic
the saddest part of the state of the
union very few people have pointed this
out was this moment where
joe biden was trying desperately to name
he didn't have any accomplishments that
he could name so he just kept talking
about things in the future right he was
instead of talking about the state of
the union right now and as a result of
the last year of his leadership you just
say you know in the future we're going
to do this and next year we'll get we'll
cure cancer and five years from now
we're gonna have uh gumdrop candy
mountain that's gonna be really great
at one point though the democrats
started chanting
usa usa
[Applause]
economist
so
that was coming from the democrats the
usa usa usa and when i heard it it
struck me as so
foreign and artificial and i said why
why is this so strange to me because
i've never heard democrats ever chant
usa usa neither have you even for our
liberal listeners out there our democrat
listeners out there i think if you're
being really honest with yourself you
can admit democrats don't do that
that's a republican thing to do
right because what democrats do is they
protest the american flag
they
teach in schools that america is a
racist bigoted terrible country that's
always been awful to black people and
minorities and indians and women and
every everyone who's not a straight
white man with blonde hair and blue eyes
america's just really been awful they
spread evil all around the world we're
just the worst country ever and we've
got nothing to be proud of
that's what the democrats teach okay but
what i think happened is the democrats
got their pollsters out there and they
know that this is a midterm election
year and they realized that hating
america doesn't play very well in peoria
and so they said okay we've got to
change this hey democrats and all the
members of congress have a script for
these things so they've got the little
script okay applaud here stand up here
and i guess one of them was chant usa
usa just try do an impersonation of a
republican do an impersonation of a
conservative during the trump
administration standing up usa usa you
could see on the deus up there behind
joe biden you have nancy pelosi and
kamala harris and they're there for the
usa usa and they don't know what to do
they don't they're not chanting they're
kind of clapping in the rhythm there's
i've never heard this before ah you usa
you as it reminded me during kovid
you remember andrew cuomo before he fell
from grace andrew cuomo was caught on
camera he said
you know
donald trump says make america great
again america was never that great
america was never that great
that's what he said damning line i think
he was speaking for a lot of democrats
don't forget andrew cuomo is considered
a moderate democrat so it wasn't even
some fringe line but they just believed
america was never that great
and then that got him into a little bit
of trouble and then he goes to the
democrat national convention and he
gives one of the speeches and he says
we're america strong we're to where
america america always does great stuff
where
you think buddy you don't really believe
that it rings hollow and it rang hollow
last night
the creepiest moment i thought of the
whole state of the union was at the very
end when joe biden started to ratchet up
the radicalism a little bit and he
started pushing his radical abortion law
to codify roe vs wade which very
possibly could be overturned in the new
supreme court session he wanted to
codify that into law so even if the
court gets rid of the fake
constitutional right to abortion it'll
still be a national law and every state
in the country is going to have to kill
babies and no state no people has the
right to say no we don't want to kill
babies in texas or tennessee so joe
biden was talking about that he came up
with a new
euphemism
for abortion
advancing liberty and justice also
requires protecting the rights of women
the constitution right affirmed by roe v
wade standing precedent for half a
century is under attack as never before
if you want to go forward not backwards
we must protect access to health care
preserve a woman's right to choose and
continue to advance maternal health care
for all americans
maternal health care we've heard a lot
of euphemisms for abortion over the
years
we've heard reproductive rights ironic
because abortion stops reproduction and
it's not right we've heard women's
health care which is very very vague
right i call my grandmother i say hey
grandma how are you doing she she
doesn't say well michael you know my hip
hurts and my friend died and the car
broke down but hey at least i have my
right to abortion right that's not what
all women mean by health quite the
opposite
but this was the first time i'd ever
heard this one and it's the most
ghoulish one of all
maternal health care
see the democrats use these euphemisms
for abortion because they don't want to
admit that abortion it necessarily
involves killing a baby so they won't
even acknowledge that the baby is real
most of the time they'll say no it's
just women's health oh it's just a minor
medical procedure it's just it's
reproductive rights
right the right
they'll equate it with contraception the
idea that you're not even you're you're
gonna stop it before it even becomes a
baby
but
maternal health care
is acknowledging that the woman getting
an abortion is already a mother
maternal health care is acknowledging
that the baby really is a baby in the
fullest sense of the word you're calling
the woman getting an abortion mommy
and mommy is going to snuff out her
little baby
if joe biden has his way and mommies
aren't even going to have the right to
get together and pass laws in their
states to outlaw killing babies if joe
biden gets his way
that is some spooky stuff from allegedly
the moderate democrat from allegedly the
catholic joe biden
i'm a legend i'm you know i'm personally
pro-life but politically i'm pro-choice
he used to do that you remember that
that was a little song and dance that
democrats came up with decades ago to
get themselves out of that tight spot on
abortion especially catholic democrats
mario cuomo did it in new york
but now they've totally gotten rid of
that and joe biden doesn't believe a
damn thing that he pretends to believe
in all he cares about is
saying the things that are popular in
his party and maintaining power
so now he says yeah it's maternal health
care
yeah yeah it's a baby yeah you
pro-lifers you were right it's a baby
and we're coming for him spooky spooky
stuff and then the silliest line of the
night was when joe biden
said that what democrats support is not
defunding the police not abolishing the
police actually democrats want to fund
the police
proven strategies like community
violence interruption trusted messengers
breaking the cycle of violence and
trauma
giving young people some hope
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police
is to fund the police
fund them
fund them yeah fund the poll that's what
we support we're democrats we support
funding the police
even though we just spent two years
actual not only threatening to defund
the police not only having aoc say
abolish the police means abolish the
police it doesn't mean move money around
it means you're actually going to get
rid of the police rashida talib ilhan
omar not just them but da's democrat
governors mayors all around the country
actually defunding the police that's why
we have an historic crime surge right
now you've got murders in particular
violent crime way way up over the last
years because of actual democrat
policies that were already implemented
and then joe biden gaslights everyone
says we support funding the police
no you don't no you don't like
prove it buster
well no and then all the democrats they
stand up there and they applaud they
haven't changed one iota of their policy
they haven't pushed for a tough on crime
bill in the congress those people who
were in that that room just there i
haven't seen a democrat tough on crime
bill anywhere in the country so it's
just a lie it just they realize that
voters around the country don't like it
that now that gang bangers are shooting
bullets through their windows and that
they know that democrats are directly
responsible for this and so they say
okay guys hey let's get us through
november we support funding the police
don't we no you don't it's just total bs
and then i'm not even that's all i'm
going to play of the of the state of the
union i can't bear i sat through it once
i don't need to sit through it again all
right i did i did my duty to you people
because i know that you didn't watch it
so i i sat there i took the slings and
arrows
it was a good way to get ready for this
penitential season i sat there and i did
it but i'm not watching it again the
first
10 to 20 minutes of it though
were not a state of the union address
the first 10 to 20 minutes were
a state of the putin address i don't did
he even mention america during the first
20 minutes i don't i don't think so i
was waiting for him i said it's the
state of the nato state of the european
union all he was talking about was
ukraine and he didn't offer any anything
productive on ukraine he didn't say
here's how we're going to end this war
here's how we're not going to escalate
and avoid world war 3. here's how here's
what we should have done differently
because very specific biden policies led
to this moment in ukraine as i covered
on the show some days ago
no he didn't talk about any of that he
just talked vaguely about this war in
ukraine and because the war in ukraine
is the best thing to happen to the biden
administration i'm damning with faint
praise he's failed on every single front
but it's the best thing that happened
previously the best thing that happened
to biden was kovid because he could
blame all of his problems on kovid but
then a lot of his predictions about kova
didn't come true a lot of his
prescriptions turned out to not work at
all and so kovid's no longer a positive
for him even in the polls the best thing
he can do now is say i'm a wartime
president i'm going to avoid world war
iii i'm gonna stave it off through my
genius state statesmanship and diplomacy
and basically what he was using the
reason he talked about ukraine at the
top of the speech was he knew that
people were going to tune out eventually
and he he wanted to avoid talking about
what he was actually doing at home
because he was such a failure so he just
basically gave a news report on what was
happening in in ukraine but the
situation is growing worse there day by
day and biden is doing absolutely
nothing off to stab to stave off what
could be potentially a much larger
potentially nuclear
war if you have not noticed already the
daily wire does not stop growing i walk
through the hallways here there are 75
new people every hour basically it's
hard to keep up well we've got a new
show crane and company it is just more
evidence the daily wire is going to keep
on chugging along crane and company is a
daily sports show hosted by former
athletes and coaches jake crane blaine
crane and david cohn they are joining
forces with the daily wire to bring you
all the sports you love with none of the
woke nonsense attached when you tune
into craning company you will be getting
in-depth sports analysis informative
interviews predictions and wagers and
constant live chat engagement with with
the listeners tune in
live today 3 p.m eastern every weekday
at dailywire.com or on youtube you can
also listen to the podcast on apple
podcasts or the platform of your choice
i would really recommend you go and
subscribe on apple podcasts right now
because the show is jumping up the
charts it's really going to irritate
espn so let's let's go do it give them
five-star review also notebook
is too controversial for the daily wire
to take on that is why we've started our
own publishing wing called dw books
we're excited to be publishing 12
seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly the true story of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
shooting mattingly is 20-year police
veteran he takes readers inside his
department's response and debunks the
lies that have been recklessly shared
with the public take a listen it was
very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i knew i was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
gets so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid in a world where voices like his or
censor this story is incredibly
important we're so grateful to have this
brave truth-teller on board the book's
out march 15th it's available for
pre-order now on amazon or anywhere you
buy your books online so get your
pre-ordered copy today because i can
promise you it will sell out we'll be
right back with a lot more
joe biden did not stave off world war
iii during his state of the union
he he staved off my alertness during the
state of the union he brought me
to sleep during most of the state of the
union that was i did get some relaxation
for that hour but the situation in
ukraine remains
very very dangerous and it's getting
more dangerous
because the head of ukraine vladimir
zelinski is now applying for for
membership in the european union he's
been applying for membership in the
european union for a long time actually
his aggressive application to join the
european union might be one of the
reasons that this war broke out in the
first place
the war is the fault of vladimir putin
there's no question about that he is the
aggressive party he's the invading party
but
wars are complicated and foreign policy
is very complicated and one of the
events that led to this moment was the
aggressive turn of ukraine away from
russia toward the west toward nato
toward the european union so zolensky
says okay our country is being invaded
we want to join europe immediately
the european parliament just voted to
advance ukraine's petition to join the
eu they voted
637 in favor 13 against 26 chose to
abstain
so this is going to be my least popular
opinion today but you know look i'm not
going to pander i'm not going to lie to
you i'm not just going to say things to
get the applause of the crowds i'm going
to give you the truth darn it and the
truth is this ukraine should not be in
the european union it's a terrible idea
it's a terrible idea and frankly if
ukraine had not been pushing for this
it's not just ukraine's fault
it's not even maybe primarily ukraine's
fault it's europe's fault it's nato's
fault it's america's fault in some ways
that ukraine has been pushing for this
be as a result of that push the
situation in ukraine is much more
dangerous as a result of that push which
was pushed almost exclusively by
democrat politicians the situation in
america in europe in the west generally
is much more dangerous today what do i
mean by that
foreign policy is not so simple as
us versus them
us good them bad
we take over more territory they lose
territory everything's hunky-dory
foreign policy is not
not that great i have i totally
understand why ukraine wants to join the
european union if ukraine joins the
european union ukraine's
younger citizens in particular can leave
ukraine and that's what a lot of it is
about they want to leave ukraine because
ukraine does not have a great economy
does not have great social prospects so
like a lot of people in eastern europe
they want to flee their countries and go
to the more prosperous western states
and before brexit so that they could go
to the united kingdom even and
be wealthier and and have a more
prosperous life that's what a lot of it
is about beyond that vladimir putin is
an autocrat and a bully and a jerk and
so ukraine does not want to be
too closely tied to putin they want to
be more closely
some people in ukraine want to be more
closely tied to the west and the west
has welcomed this and encouraged this
there is such a thing as buffer states
at least there used to be
you know i'll give you another good
example of this during this war that's
broken out in ukraine switzerland did
something really unusual switzerland
took a side switzerland famously remains
neutral during wars
not even the nazis can get switzerland
to stop remaining neutral switzerland
has survived for so long as a unified
political
community in no small part because they
remain neutral why do they remain
neutral in part it's because of their
geography in part it's because of their
history neutral states
and buffer states
can be a very good thing they can help
the world order do we think it's a
really great idea
for two rival powers
nato slash the european union slash
america because it's american leadership
right up totally sharing a huge border
in really crucial areas with russia
its own power which is not part of
europe which is not part of nato which
is not part of the west as we understand
it
do we think it's a good idea for two
really
strong rival powers to just be totally
up against one one another everywhere
all along the border no i think that's a
dumb idea that historically doesn't work
out very well that's why there's such a
thing as buffer states and for buffer
states to remain
relatively safe they've got to play both
sides they've got to maintain decent
enough relationships with
both of the rival powers that's what
ukraine had been doing for a long time
then the west believed leading up to
2013 2014 that ukraine was a little too
friendly to russia or not sufficiently
friendly to europe so what
the western powers did was encourage
protests and actually
fund protests in ukraine to oust the
somewhat neutral slightly more
pro-russian government to install a more
pro-western government
then in 2017 you saw a big push by
ukraine to join nato and the eu that has
only increased in 20 2020 and 2021 and
now you see war break out why would war
break out because yes putin is a jerk
he's a terrible guy he kills journalists
he's a horrible person
vladimir putin
also sees that russia has interests and
it is very much not in russia's
interests for ukraine to be a full-on eu
european nato member state
that vladimir putin says it's an
intolerable security threat whether or
not that's true or not he might be
exaggerating things but in terms of
russia's interest this is really bad
had ukraine remained basically a buffer
state
i seriously doubt there would be a war
there right now i don't think putin
would have invaded as far as he did i
mean frankly his invasion of crimea came
as a result of the of what happened in
2013 and 2014 in ukraine would he have
even invaded crimea had the government
not changed then i'm not so sure
whether he would have or not i don't
think he would have seen this full-scale
invasion right now i made this point
much earlier
about a week ago when the war broke out
i said if you want to understand your
enemy if you want to do well in war if
you want to have an advantage in war you
need to understand your enemy it's not
enough to say putin hitler putin bad i i
hate putin he's crazy he's a crazy
person and he's just doing crazy things
so there's no way to understand him yeah
maybe he's got some problems but i think
he is also largely a rational actor who
is pursuing the national interest of
russia and if you want to maintain world
peace you've got to balance those
interests and just having nato and the
european union gobble up everything
is not necessarily the most prudent
strategy well what about ukraine they
don't want to be tied to this lunatic
putin they want to they want to join
europe yeah maybe they do
but maybe maybe that's not the most
prudent thing for them to do buffer
states are a good thing joram pezoni the
israeli philosopher pointed this out
yesterday
he said jordan has remained basically
neutral they've acted as a kind of
mediator between israel and the arab
world
for many decades that's a good thing
it's it's actually kind of nice to have
those buffers it's nice to have states
where
the great powers don't feel threatened
and they can actually talk to one
another
but our leadership
will will not engage in that kind of
sophisticated it's not even that
sophisticated it's kind of basic
thinking
today it might be considered
sophisticated it used to be considered
elementary they refused to do that so
nancy pelosi she goes on television she
goes on msnbc and she says all the you
know the reason for this you know what
led to this
invasion it's be as putin
it's because putin had covid and his
brain is all foggy
i don't know what is the matter there
i've talked to heads of state who have
met with him and uh they just take at
face value the evil that he is putting
forth as something that we have to deal
with they're not making a diagnosis of
his health some people say he has cancer
and some people say he has brain fog
from um
kovid
other people just think he's a complete
raging fully but whatever it is the
people of ukraine are paying the price
for it
now the only true thing she said there
well a couple yes he's a bully yes he's
a bad guy
the people of ukraine are paying the
price
does vladimir putin have cancer i don't
know maybe i'm not his doctor does
vladimir putin has he been feeling a
little under the weather since kovid i
yeah maybe i don't know i don't he
didn't invade ukraine
because of brain fog from kovid
you simple-headed woman
you oh my this is why we got into this
mess is because of this kind of stupid
sophomoric thinking about foreign policy
vladimir putin believes
that it is in his interest he doesn't
just have brain fog he doesn't just have
cancer he doesn't just have some
personality disorder he has interests
okay
and mostly democrats mostly liberal
politicians in the west decided to
recklessly upend all of those interests
in ukraine
and and
they might say well it was in the
interest of the ukrainian people oh is
it i don't think that bombs raining down
on kiev is in the interest of the
ukrainian people
i don't think that needlessly provoking
the other still significant nuclear
power in the other side of ukraine is
necessarily in the ukrainian's interests
i don't think that it is in
the europeans interests i don't think
it's in america's interests i think that
we're on the brink of world war three
potentially
i don't think that's in anybody's name
for ironically the only person whose
interests this really seems to serve is
vladimir putin who at the end of this
very well may have greatly expanded his
country and conquered the bread basket
of europe that's what you get
for your simple-headed compassionate
empathetic humanitarian policy in
ukraine as ukraine doesn't exist
countless civilians are killed europe
loses an important buffer state and
russia expands smart move really really
smart stuff guys the road to hell is
paved with good intentions not that i'm
convinced that the the western liberals
who have been pushing for this policy
necessarily have good intentions i've
got the funniest fact check i have ever
read in my entire life
okay so here's the fact check from usa
today
the fact check is about a claim
that ukraine not only had obviously been
cozying up to the west for many years
before this invasion
but
that specifically they'd been cozying up
to liberal politicians in the west
because liberal politicians are the
ruling elite in the west and
specifically they'd been cozying up to
the clinton so here's the claim you
probably have seen it going around
facebook or twitter or instagram the
claim is that
ukraine was the largest donor to the
clinton foundation from 1999 to 2014.
okay and usa today takes us up they say
here's the claim similar rumors about
ukrainian financial donations to the
clinton foundation have gained traction
on twitter
representative marjorie taylor green
promoted an iteration of this claim
during a february 19th rally
fact ukraine was the single largest
owner to the clinton foundation has
gained 100 likes but the post
misrepresents a chart from 2015
which ranks individual contributions to
the foundation based on nationality as
factcheck.org reported in 2019 the
clinton foundation hasn't received
donations from the ukrainian government
want to pause it right there the post
never said
that the clinton foundation got got
money from the ukrainian government
by the way the democrat elite
political operatives have gotten money
from the ukrainian government when you
think of hunter biden for instance has a
no-show job with a state
energy company barisma in ukraine that
is the ukrainian government giving money
to democrats but okay let's put that
aside the post never says
the ukrainian government was the largest
owner to the it said ukraine
ukraine the people of ukraine
ukraine through its various
channels was the largest donor to the
clinton foundation usa today reached out
to the social medias who shared this
claim for comment do you want to recant
your claims people your stupid crazy
conspiracy theory wait a second hold on
the wall street journal
oh hold on so the headline says the
posts misuse reports on individual
donations so how do they misuse it the
wall street journal published a report
in 2015 on individual donations over 50
000 made to the clinton foundation
1999-2014
the article included a chart listing the
top foreign donors
ukraine tops the list
but the graph doesn't support the claim
in the social media posts hold on
the the social media post says from 1999
to 2014 ukraine top donor to the clinton
foundation
the fact check says
uh in in this chart from 1999 to 2014
ukraine tops the list
but the graph doesn't support the claim
that is literally the claim that is in
those exact words that is the claim
but no fact check
no it because the graph doesn't reflect
donations from the governments which the
posts aren't really focused on
uh so therefore you know it's just yeah
ukrainians contributed 10 million
dollars to the clinton foundation don't
forget by the way ukraine's a relatively
poor country
i where did this 10 million dollars come
from i don't know do you think some of
it might have come from kind of dodgy
oligarchic sources in ukraine oh i don't
know i don't know i'm just asking
questions
ukrainians contributed 10 million more
than any other nationality
most of that money came from ukrainian
businessman and philanthropist victor
pinchuk victor pinchook's foundation
based in kiev donated 8.6 million
dollars to the foundation between 2009
and 2013.
the article notes that pinchuk has close
government ties and he served as a
member of ukrainian parliament from 1998
oh and sorry he's the son-in-law of
former ukrainian president leni kuchma
this
your fact check is proving the posts to
be 100 completely correct therefore
these liberal fact checkers quote
unquote rate at 17 million pinocchio's
total lies fake news fake news censor
anyone who reports on the truth between
the democrats crooked relationship
between uh ukrainian oligarchs and
and crooked politicians here in the
united states fact check fact check
totally false totally
all the facts are true but the fact
check is false
the reason by the way
that liberals
post these ridiculous fact checks where
the headlines is fact check republican
claim totally false
fake news
and then in the article they admit that
the fact the fact the facts of the
matter were totally right
in the in the article they they note
that there are things the republicans
actually said were totally right the
reason they do that is because these
fact checking organizations have
relationships with all the big social
media companies
and the social media companies rely on
the fact checkers to determine what will
be promoted or censored in the algorithm
so even if the fact checkers quote
unquote have even the modicum of
integrity to admit that the claims are
true in the article as long as the final
verdict is that this is fake news it
will be censored
as
this sort of information has been now
for years
i tell you though
even though
the clintons have a very crooked
relationship with the ukrainian
government and even though democrat
politicians in in many ways are the
single most responsible
group of people for leading up to the
geopolitical situation in which vladimir
putin invaded ukraine even for all of
that i in some ways long for the
clintons
i long for the days i have nostalgia for
the clintons and part of that is because
at least the clintons are smart at least
the clintons are relatively competent
people
crooked
probably led to a much worse world now
that we're but at least they were sort
of
intelligent
the same cannot be said for our current
ruling class kamala harris went on a
radio show
just yesterday she was asked to explain
the situation in ukraine and she she did
the best she could
if you're watching any level of news
even social media you're seeing
everything that's going on right now in
the ukraine break it down to layman's
terms for people who don't understand
what's going on and how can this
directly affect the people of the united
states so
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
next to another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so
basically that's wrong
so the man said break it down in
layman's terms he did not say
explain this to a toddler
he did
i
i don't know
talk about the soft bigotry of low
expectations i don't know what kamala
harris thinks of the listeners to this
radio program
but i
i bet they've probably heard of russia
before
i i have enough respect for the
listeners to this random radio they
probably know
like what a country is you know and what
russia is and layman's terms darling
what does it mean why did it start what
can we do about it now who are the
political players you don't need to go
into some high
political theory you don't need to be
quoting maternique to to
do this but you can at least treat
people like they're
respectable adults who know what the
nation of russia is but caballeros can't
do that and frankly i suspect that this
explanation pretty much encapsulates her
understanding of the situation frankly
this is a little bit more sophisticated
than most democrats have have uh seemed
to
demonstrate in their understanding of
the ukraine situation in recent years
ukraine country
russia country share border
if if democrats had known that and
admitted that for the years leading up
to this invasion very likely it wouldn't
have happened
and maybe they wouldn't have been so
aggressive about one milking that
country for all the resources it's got
sending all of their politicians kids
there to to get money out of the crooked
energy companies with obviously tacit
promises that they're going to support
ukraine militarily financially
politically have them oh yeah
oh ukraine you want to join europe oh
that sounds great you know my my son
hunter needs a job yeah no it sounds
great though and i joe biden i'm the
point person on ukraine right now and oh
yeah you want to join nato wow that
sounds that'd be pretty nice for you huh
if you join nato yeah well maybe talk to
my son hunter maybe he'll work out the
details for you hey have you heard of
the clinton global initiative you heard
the clinton foundation yeah they could
use they're putting on a few fundraisers
they could sure use 10 million dollars
if you've got it
and oh yeah no and
okay that's great oh we'd love to
support you we have a great relationship
let's deepen this friendship
what has that led to
that's led to right now
the russian annihilation
of that country great job guys
great job speaking of laymen
speaking of taking complex subjects and
trying to boil them down saturday night
live is taking on
kovid and it is at once the most
gratifying and infuriating skit i've
ever seen
i think the biggest mistake the
administration made was not providing
more testing
but the uk had done tons of testing and
had even more covert
good well at least biden finally sent
out all those tests over christmas you
mean the two tests for a family of eight
that froze in the mail
okay well at least we have the cdc i
mean they haven't always been perfect
but the science changed how does science
change when i make a mistake at work i
don't get to say the science changed
at least we had outdoor dining
oh you mean when they built a smaller
restaurant in the street how is that
outdoors
oh my god
look i went to a child's birthday party
self-careful
and they did gymnastics in masks don't
and then they went into another room and
took off their masks to eat pizza this
is the end of me
so did they really need
the mask oh no
did any of us ever
need
the mask
[Applause]
all those things that we made you do for
two years that we we the actual elite in
america the entertainment elite the news
media elite the haha it was all dumb
and all you conservatives who said it
was dumb from the beginning and we
called you nazis and killers and
murderers and took away your rights and
censored you and tried to take your kids
away from you in some cases haha you
were right
moving on
no no
you don't get to make that joke that's
not your joke that sometimes you hear
people say that's not your word that's
our word you can't use that that's not
your joke libs
that's our joke
that's our political movement that we've
been trying to do for two years and you
p you people in particular on saturday
night live you have been so vicious
so so malicious
in your persecution of anyone who didn't
want to wear the dumb mask or take the
fouchy ouchy shot that's so super duper
safe and effective and it totally stops
transmission and infection of the virus
except whoopsie days you take your fifth
one because the first four didn't work
that well you you don't get you don't
and they're just gonna move on and
they're just gonna well okay it's state
of the union okay cove it's over and
we're just gonna move on to the next
thing
this is a midterm election year please
please please people do not forget the
state of our union is not particularly
strong right now we may still have in
our power to turn things around
don't miss the opportunity i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire